Martini's let's do it Jeannie I should
make a martini for the martini how do we
have stuff I know that's true you'll
have just vodka I mean it's just vodka
for MUFAs true it's disgusting
and nobody basically tastes like don't
know what to expect the first time I had
a martini I was like that's what James
Bond lights right so James Bond like so
I was like man up [ __ ] Casey's like
if you get a really dirty martini it's
pretty good I don't like olive juice oh
you need girliest but manliest drink
yeah cuz it's martini yeah thank you
master
yes hmm stirred nah she usually
technically supposed to be stirred
people are saying like shaking it it
dilutes the water too much so you're
gonna ruin the flavor of the alcohol
that's what he prefers he wanted it to
be different DC's shaken not stirred or
stirred not shaken shaken not stirred
shaken and it sounds like he's like ruin
it he says what sounds like this is what
everyone does not me because before
James Bond was invented and became a
phenomenon the martini was meant to be a
gin drink so Jen martinis were that's a
classic one and vodka that's what I was
thinking at the time yeah poor James
ponderings vodka it's crazy how that
became so popular vodka like these
little things in movies Cosmopolitan's
became so big after Sex in the City
oh yeah I get a Cosmo I made a Cosmo
it's alright what about my mouse I gotta
make it legible SEC the good triple sec
Cointreau it's like kind of pink yeah
well the cranberry juice yeah yeah it's
alright you know low key what's really
really good juice and a good gin it has
to be a smooth gin I say Hendricks
Hendricks or [ __ ] no let's
I haven't read what's the juice here
right or any fresh any fresh fruit juice
tastes really really granite juice and
gin tastes really good with my favorite
the passion fruit thing the passion
fruit drink what's it called
you said you liked that a lot to hog hog
passion or mean with like alcohol oh the
one that you have in like a Bahama ma no
it's my little my time
No haha Dios [ __ ] [ __ ]
drink it like every day in Vietnam
oh the jackfruit no passion fruit no
food let me help you oh I'll think of it
I'll come back it's a Vietnamese drink
no it's just any country that has a lot
of passion fruit they may drink it a lot
of countries are you guys gonna travel
2020 did you have any travel plans we
were supposed to be in the Dominican
Republic for an alcohol brandy Yoshi and
it was braum so fun yes rum yes and it's
a company I love I've already I last
time I traveled was to Vietnam for them
that company and it was really fun and
that's when Nick Nick Jonas hit me in
the mouth with the pineapple and I
chipped my suit
it just seemed kind of happy no I mean
it was kind of a fun story because it's
like yeah I chipped my tooth sliding
down a gigantic water slide in Vietnam
while Nick Jonas through pineapples at
my face it was the [ __ ] pineapple I
mean it was a pineapple it was a rubber
pineapple I pictured a real pineapple
you're supposed to so he's on an island
and you slide down this giant waterslide
and as you shoot up he throws it and
you're trying to gonna try to catch it
okay before it goes nobody could catch
it zero people could catch it and he was
I guess he was a baseball pitcher so he
was actually pretty good at throwing a
fastball my tooth chipped though what he
said he bought it Nick Jonas he said
nothing [ __ ] did you guys get to hang
out like quite a bit he I mean he was
there like during the parties and stuff
but I didn't try to talk to him I
actually didn't really know him like I
didn't know who was Jumanji right yeah I
never really watched Jonas Brothers
right that's Nick yes Nick right now
yeah he's big like buddy because they're
like a Lister yeah yeah Jonas Brothers
is huge in Japan to huge musician he
married someone
a musician actor I think anyone who
performs during the ball drop at New
Year's is pretty big drew both he was
really cholo
then his brother made Sophie yeah Sophie
kupatana no no from Game of Thrones I
like so time sophie Turner yes name and
gibbehh throne Sansa yeah she marries Oh
but is Sam saw a redhead yes in real
life no she's blonde in her right now I
don't know what her at natural hair
color is but I've never studied her
scalp that deeply oh she's blond right
with a wildling she didn't marry a
northerner I was supposed to be in a
turkey
cuz I'm gonna go get veneers there why
they're known for veneers yeah we're
done I'm afraid of getting anything
medical outside of the US I wouldn't
want you there like because in America
they the dentist when it takes so
[ __ ] long to do it why they're lazy
no it's because the huge machines that
they have to make actual like to see
like the ceramic little thing that they
used to make your tooth
yeah they have to send all of things out
to another company to do that Wow
because it cost so much that that a
regular dental practice that just has
like office like this they're not gonna
buy the whole machine just for that so
they have to sit now so they give you
fake teeth oh you have to walk around
with for two months over there they just
do it like and you come back the next
day and it's done Wow and then it's like
oh if you don't like how it fits they
adjusted they make it longer do whatever
so you get a customized your teeth and
everything plus in America they charged
so much [ __ ] more than what it's
actually worth because they charge per
tooth like way [ __ ] more like
shipping and handling I heard that
there's medical tourism like people go
to Thailand for sex change they go to
Korea for I need the legal protection of
America also but the thing is the ones
in Turkey are also backed by the Dental
Association so they have to buy American
Dental Association the world and then
it's like so it's it's properly done but
the deck the doctors there aren't here
that the drive around Lambos and like
super [ __ ] balling
they just make regular money because
here they can like anything medical in
America is gonna be way more [ __ ]
each other crazy premium yeah anything
that involves insurance yeah my doctor's
not driving a Lamborghini I don't trust
them I see some like if you go to a
super celebrity doctor
they look amazing but if you go to a
regular one out here they got jacked up
teeth from yeah everyone - yeah
yeah I was supposed to be in April I
suppose be in Tennessee because we
bought tickets to the Chappelle Joe
Rogan stand-up but then when this whole
thing happened they cancelled it but
they rescheduled for September so I'm
really excited Tennessee yeah because
I'm like you know what I've been a like
Dave Chappelle is like my comedy idol
and I'm like I if that's like my job I
have to see the person that inspired me
like crazy and I remember like I really
wanted to see Michael Jackson and
literally that year he passed away we
were gonna go this is it concert yeah so
I'm like I don't I don't want to have
like another Great Escape oh he was
gonna expose the Illuminati plan us but
I got to kill him yeah is that the what
that's what the conspiracy is because
all of it just watch this is it the
[ __ ] documentary everything all of
his life's work was going toward that
exposing all that [ __ ] listen to the
music man what should I start with to
get to yet they all kind of suck because
the new stuff just doesn't it's boring
isn't like the old knob but then there's
like messages yeah so I'm mixed I'm
really excited to see Dave Chappelle in
person and also to see you've never seen
him perform before I've never seen him
perform in real life mmm I'm not just I
just heard stories of him just coming in
to comedy clubs and he showed I feed him
who actually performed and he's just
crazy just perform sometimes I'll be
like 10 minutes I'll be three hours I
was at an Ali Wong show yeah he was just
next door and he just showed up and he
went on the stage and he did like a 10
minute bit because he was just like yep
I was next door so I'm over here now
giving you guys the opening show yeah
we're like what did he open now he
opened for Ali Wong yeah with like no
prior planning he just showed up we went
to like a like a Monday night show
in New York for the Comedy Cellar and
like it was me and my dad and we just
like wanted to go to a comedy club and
have fun and like see all the you know
the New York comedy clubs and Chris Rock
came in and did a two-hour set just cuz
randomly he was working on a set and he
dropped by yeah I've wanted to practice
his material yeah like that a lot of
them just do that like if they're
planning a new set to tour with they'll
just drop by the clubs and like work
[ __ ] out and like see what gets the most
laughs and take those and then polish
those that's like their practice mm-hmm
yeah we watched Jeff Garlin do his when
what go see Bobby Lee
oh yeah Jeff Garlin jumped on stage and
he was just kind of like working stuff
off of cards yeah that's true
that's actually the reason why I quit
stand-up because I was doing it and then
because I'm goes like a no-name or for
Tuesday Thursday nights and then I'll
have to come on at 8:00 and at that time
it's like you got a call like brainer
shows so they don't even buckle I should
bring up one or two people yeah they're
rough yeah and I bring like a bunch of
people and then because all these celebs
just keep popping in then I tell all my
friends I'm there at 8:00 and I don't
really even go on until 11:00 yeah but
I'm like [ __ ] this it's rough let's go
back to YouTube we're just ordering
drinks or like there's a one drink
minimum oh no it just spends like if you
stay longer after buy more sometimes we
use it like exactly like like recently I
was working on a new set and it was like
a 15-minute set of all new material and
so I was doing different shows and I was
working on it and I like did a Instagram
I didn't want to heavily promote a show
that I was like working on new material
for but I wanted like you know some
people know about it so I just I posted
an Instagram story for like two hours
like hey I'm gonna show tonight and then
took it down and there were enough
people that showed up that like like a
small crowd but then they the club used
that since they were all waiting to see
me go on they like put me farther down
the lineup
yeah basically like I'm more giving my
[ __ ] yeah and so like they had to sit
through some very mediocre yeah I'm done
like going like the havoc the people
that supposed to be on and then they had
their friends come on they're still like
learning it yeah yeah that's kind of
what people are like kind of leaving
already
and then after like one of the my
favorite moments was uh Donnell Rawlings
came on like ABS a five-piece funny just
by himself though dude
it was he was literally just tired of
you when people just like time around so
you go on too many bits I've never
laughed so much at from like a comedy
thing then his and this is after the
whole moons gone and I just keep can't
find my way to slip out cuz I'm gonna
walk out during the middle of an act and
like is why they're transitioning I like
still can't find my way out cuz I stay
at the front but he made everyone like
people more people trying to come back
in Saudi [ __ ] dude he's so who I
was impressed with recently I was able
to catch Theo's set oh cool mark I was
in Minnesota with them coincidentally on
this at the same like van yeah and he
was opening and it was just like some
big business thing then they hired him
for and it was [ __ ] good dude like
I've never seen him do that I just you
know we talked to him he had him here on
podcast but him on just doing live I was
in tears from laughing he's so funny
asthma yeah he's [ __ ] killing it dude
I was like damn that was good you know
was killing you right now
you guys had on air Griffin still in a
game really and gaming he's a whole
gaming stream that's killing [ __ ] his
commentary really funny he's funny but
he's [ __ ] good at gaming I never
thought I thought he was like an old
grandpa or uncle looking guy yeah he
doesn't like a whole uncle yeah I was
like dad these people are like weird but
it's also funny just like Dean la how
many people you actually know just likes
being in a small industry like you know
the top people immediately we all know
yeah it's one degree separation here
yeah we're like one degree away from Joe
Rogan yeah it's just that one degrees of
far degree though
let me live like maybe two blocks from
his studio I heard I heard he has like
hello security issues I bet we have were
multiple one degrees from Joe Rogan
actually Bobby Lee's one of them
Bobby Lee feel wand mark Bell oh yeah
Eric Griffin I had a lot of
conversations with Dave Chappelle - so
did ya I've told him on here before cuz
he was super high he got freaked out
that I said his name what I ain't said
it at a restaurant yeah was a cocktail
server David yeah
but it was yeah
[Music]
[Music]